across the United States you'll find a
religiously maintained bed of grass
that's usually no more than four
centimeters tall
the American lawn it's everywhere
arranged in such a strict basic design
it's as uniquely American in the 21st
and 20th Century as it was unique for
the British and French Elite in the 18th
America was not always a land of turf
grass the American lawn is an invention
like any other and it's an invention
that can kind of suck
when European colonists arrived in the
new world they were greeted with a thin
selection of cereals such as little
barley and corn
and this was a problem because livestock
from the old world expects old crops the
annual grasses were nutritionally weak
and needed to be replanted and
alternative food for livestock was
either not abundant or inedible
so the colonists wrote back to their old
countries demanding the supply of their
older grasses
unintended weeds also spread such as
couch grass not grass and the dandelion
and then there's POA pretensis the alpha
of turf grasses a perennial cool season
grass native to all of Europe known for
being highly palatable for livestock and
producing large yields
technically an invasive it's one of the
most popular grasses in the United
States
it was the demand for high-yield pasture
grass that introduced the materials but
there's a key difference between fields
of grass that are trimmed by animals and
Fields of grass where no animals can be
found
Elan becomes a lawn when it has the
aesthetic qualities of pasture without
the actual presence of livestock and
that makes Elan a difficult thing
Turf grasses are designed for grazed
environments in a grazed environment is
not a pleasant one
for many plants your reproduction and
growth happens high so if you reproduce
where predator's mouth begins you're
going to have problems as true for
plants as it is for mammals but grasses
are monoclidodons it's not how you say
it they grow at their base and this is
important because when eaten from the
top they can still survive and grow as
long as the crown remains grass will too
turf grass co-evolved with grazing
mammals who have teeth specifically
designed for consuming the grit that
comes with grass it's a hearty plant
that doesn't just survive where grazing
animals roam it flourishes able to
reproduce asexually it out competes
plants that need to reproduce from the
top and is able to survive constant
cutting
this is where the problem starts
monocultured grass needs to be trimmed
if you wanted to stay uniform and green
and also if you want to keep it at a
manageable height but if you're not
going to use a cow in the 1700s you're
going to be using labor often
involuntary
and there were only a few powerful
American men who could afford that
located in the U.S state Virginia is
Thomas Jefferson's Home Monticello
remarkable for being an architectural
Masterpiece single-handedly designed by
President of the United States and
founding father
what makes Monticello especially unique
though is that it's also the location of
one of the first true American Lawns a
near perfect combination of European
landscape design but located thousands
of kilometers away from the place it
comes from
a formalized idea of a lawn was the
brainchild of a Frenchman Andre Notre he
developed a wide range of gardens in
France including Versailles where he
treated gardening as a three-dimensional
art implementing complex grids with
different permutations and patterns that
manipulated your senses so that you'd
perceive scale that wasn't there
it's not who's credited with creating
the Green carpet a plane of flat grass
that created the illusion of a
never-ending straight line helping
represent the infinite scale of the sun
King's power and the French male ego
the lawn was born in France but it grew
up in England where the formal really
strict tradition would ease up a bit
relax you know and it's in England where
Jefferson would end up traveling through
as the American Minister for France
there he would visit key locations where
he would see the product of the British
genius William Kent
Kent was like any other British man he
had a difficulty with maintaining a
healthy relationship with alcohol while
using deprecating humor to mask
deep-seated trauma and depression
we started as a painter and also made
valuable contributions towards British
architecture but is his impact on
landscape design that is the most
important
where the traditional French use of
grass was formal arranged in complex
geometrical shapes and intended for the
use of grandeur what Kent helped create
was a lawn design that navigated a fine
line between that French tradition while
respecting certain aspects of nature
that were there to begin with
where the French lawn was kind of kitsch
and in your face the new English lawn
was still kind of kitsch and in your
face
but in a subtle way
it's Kent and another man who
popularized the English landscape design
that was more natural
a subtle use of lakes Groves of trees
and also random temples as though the
British aristocracy didn't have enough
reasons to come off pretentious of these
Gardens though the most important
feature that Kent largely popularized
not invented was a haha a design that
set in motion the separation between
pasture and Lawn
haha is the sunken fence that creates
the illusion of a continuous landscape
while also separating livestock from
being too close to the home for the
elite this is convenient you can flaunt
that you have long billowy fields of
grass just for the sake of it maintain
the use of perspective without being
exposed to livestock but you also reduce
the need for additional labor to cover
the entire field which are now only
needed on a section of the raised land
and this is what Jefferson helped bring
back to America the idea of having a
large section of land that mimic pasture
without having livestock to actually go
on it it was as true for Monticello as
it was for Mount Vernon George
Washington's house where he commanded
and oversaw the construction of not one
but three haha walls with hundreds of
slaves sithing and weeding those Lawns
on a consistent basis
and it took years of incremental
improvements in lawn equipment for the
input costs of running a lawn to be
reduced enough so that it could become a
luxury that could be afforded by the
middle class
and it was after World War II that the
American lawn as we know it really began
a returning base of World War II
veterans were rewarded with subsidized
homeownership opening the doors for new
types of development
and this is where a chicken egg problem
emerges a question a scientist can
answer but not someone who makes YouTube
videos was it a demand of incoming new
homeowners that spurred the development
of green Lawns because Lawns were always
seen as a status symbol and demanded or
did it largely happen in Reverse where a
few developers with their own ideas of
what was desirable helped create that
Demand by chance
I don't know but what I do know is that
there's a landscape architect and
developer that's still important to
mention here Olmstead one of the most
influential Americans in history he
designed New York City's Central Park
and Prospect Park and was also the first
landscape architect for the U.S Capitol
but he also helped design another thing
the American suburb
Riverside is a suburb near Chicago it's
recognized as one of the first planned
Suburban communities in the United
States designed by Olmsted and one other
it's in Riverside that he equipped homes
with Lawns intended as public Green
Space by demanding setbacks spatial
requirements that separated a home from
the public Street
it's Olmstead that helped popularize
generous setbacks as a standard model
for suburban homes
and in the U.S everything is bigger and
that also means the setbacks which are
larger than a European alternative were
Turf grasses are actually naturally
occurring so when Suburbia increased
setbacks and The Lawns that came with it
Rose as well
but this is where the painful irony
emerges
spend any time in northern Europe or in
the British Isles generally and you'll
be overwhelmed by large billowing fields
of green pasture everywhere it's
honestly kind of boring it's as though
the large green fields of grass are
natural which well they kind of are
see you can try and bring grasses from
the old country to the new but bringing
the environment with you you cannot most
Turf grasses are made for the moist less
varied cool climate of northern Europe
not for the more variable weather
conditions of North America
but a plant not being natural doesn't
mean that plant can be naturalized
humans are animals after all you're a
monkey don't ever forget it and much
like other animals humans can also
distribute seeds naturally but to get
the environment of grass in the U.S to
be like it is in northern Europe still
requires more external intervention be
it water and nutrients or pesticides and
the need to actively create a new
environment has never stopped Americans
from producing the lawn
and produce it they do
lawn mowing used to be a communal Family
Affair a father would pick out a son
with the smallest chance of going to a
liberal arts college and he would
educate him in the practice of lawn
mowing but this has left its humble
Origins the scale of the Landscaping
industry has grown
what started with a rotary push mower
dangerous enough has developed into the
zero turn lawnmower a perfect example of
the large-scale efficiency gains in the
industry widely adopted because it can
turn in place small gains in time that
compound over time
Millions upon millions are spent on the
industry ranging from pesticides
irrigation contracts to different types
of mowers but maybe the best example of
the bizarreness of the American
Landscaping industry is the leaf blower
leaves are actually desirable for a lawn
they break down and provide fertilizer
that doesn't produce runoff which is
beneficial for the green colored Lawns
that homeowners desire but a lawn
covered in leaves is a lawn that can't
be seen usually a rake would be
sufficient but a rake takes time and
after mowing your lawn you're also often
left with clippings leftover pieces of
grass that also serve a useful
fertilizing role but they are also seen
as aesthetically displeasing
instead of leaving both leaves and
clippings or at least using a rake on
both of them it's been decided that they
must both be taken away with heavy
machinery and that Machinery brings
problems
leaf blowers have a high pitched
screeching wine
it's impossible to think leaf blowers
have engines that go thousands of
revolutions per minute three times the
speed of a car engine and if standing 15
meters away from a blower you'll
experience around 68 to 76 decibels of
noise
that's a lot but for the operator it's
even louder 98 to 106 more than enough
to cause permanent hearing loss and then
there's also the other damage the
two-stroke engine of a leaf blower is
widely inefficient producing more than
10 times the amount of carbon monoxide
as a new light vehicle and more than 40
times the particulate matter
and it's that engine that's attached to
the back of a laborer who not only has
to face potential permanent hearing loss
but also dangerous fumes on an hourly
basis for days weeks years on end
but what makes the relationship between
America and long even weirder is how the
US is seen
many think of the U.S as a country of
individuality there's a unique ability
for one to hold property and act in a
certain way that should not be treaded
on it's a country more interested in
negative freedom than positive when
compared to the others
but wide-scale lawn adoption by your
neighbors is most definitely treading on
you and impacting your freedom
own a piece of property that is
connected to a water supply and it's
likely that wide scale use of nitrogen
fertilizers from your neighbors can
produce runoff that causes algae blooms
on yours decreasing oxygen in the water
and killing organisms on your property
someone is treading on you
decide that you'd like to stop mowing
your lawn and let it grow to its natural
state you want to exercise your freedom
but doing this can cause you to be fined
and face legal consequences people
directly treading on you
decide that you'd like to grow native
plants help return a well-functioning
ecosystem of insects and small mammals
and you'll likely still face a wide use
of pesticides that run off onto your
property and kill them slowly pesticides
are varied and have come a long way from
substances like lead arsenic an
insecticide used on lawns that could
create permanent long-lasting brain
damage in children
but today plenty of pesticides are still
used with somewhat vague effects
one of the most common insecticide
groups used by the Landscaping industry
in the U.S and also agriculture is
neonectinoids accounting for 25 percent
of the global pesticide Market the
European commission Band 3 clothianidene
Immaculate and theom thoxam due to their
ability to harm food chains and its
connection to honeybee colony collapse
disorder they're a very efficient
invertebrate killer but in the U.S there
are no bans there's also carboral one of
the most widely used insecticides in the
Landscaping industry in the U.S also
banned by the European commission for
being highly toxic to Aquatic Life and
its potential to cause cancer in the U.S
it's only recently getting removed from
residential use
but the effects of pesticides are
complex the age of a person in dosage
matters pesticides can come in complex
cocktails and there's also a
conversation to be had about needing to
produce food at scale with adequate Pest
Management agriculture is a different
Beast than a lawn
but on your property don't you have the
right to determine what intentionally
applied substances have a chance of
leeching onto your land a land where
your children can still play with
developing brains
a land where you attempt to demonstrate
what makes your country so beautiful in
the first place
if you don't have that right isn't that
a perfect example of your neighbors and
Community treading on you
this is the amount of hours you have in
a week and this is the amount of time
you spend on your phone
what would happen if you were to turn
just one hour of those multiple hours
each day into an hour of math and
science
what kind of person would you be in a
year if you did that every day
brilliant is not just interesting
because it makes you better able to
understand physical reality Through Math
and Science but it's also interesting
because it's a tool that fundamentally
improves you multiple hours a day
mindlessly scrolling can make anyone
feel guilty about their phone addiction
but spending a few hours with your phone
each day and getting better at math now
that's something easier to justify
brilliant makes you a formidable person
you can get it right now without moving
and at brilliant.org the first 200
subscribers who decide to take that
first step and get 20 off on a tool that
is guaranteed to give you some of your
life and time back
[Music]